استدعاء قذيفه بيوم بي في اليوم الاخير
للمناورات الجويه الاكبر بين سولوا واشنطن
هو استعراض للقوه ورساله امريكيه مباشره
لكوريا
من الاسلحه المواجهه وغير المواجهه
قذفت دي ونبيل لديها اربعه محركات نفاثه
ويمكنها التحليق بسرعه تزيد على 1500 كيلو
متر في الساعه
44 مترا ونصفا وارتفاعه نحو عشره امتار
ونصف ووزنها نحو 86 طنا
تصميم قذيفه يجعلها قادره على الطيران
بعيد المداوي بقدره كبيره على المناوره
وتحمل والتحليق بسرعه تتجاوز سرعه الصوت
القذيفه مزوده بارادار متطور يستطيع تعقب
واستداف المركبات التي تسير على الارض
وتعقب التضاريس الارضيه
استخدمت القذيفه لاول مره في جبهات القتال
خلال عمليه ثعلب الصحراء بالعراق في
ديسمبر من عام 1990